>> Everdeen Mason: Hi, everyone.
I'm Everdeen Mason, and
I'm an audience editor
and a science fiction
fantasy columnist
at the Washington Post,
which is a charter sponsor
of the National Book Festival.
First, a few official words.
First, a thank-you to the
co-chairman of the festival,
David Rubenstein, and the
other generous sponsors
who have made this
event possible.
If you would like to add
your financial support,
please note that
information in your program.
We'll have some time after this
presentation for your questions.
And I've been asked to
remind you that if you come
to the microphone, you will
be included in the videotape
of this event, which may be
broadcast at a later date.
And the author signing will be
at line 18 from 5:30 to 6:30.
So now that we have dispensed
with the formalities,
I am pleased to introduce our
guest today, Justina Ireland.
Justina is an author of middle
grade and young adult books.
And her most recent,
the critically acclaimed Dread
Nation, is a best-seller.
You may also know her as a
strong advocate for diversity
and inclusion in
publishing industry.
Using her voice in fiction
and essays and on social media
to hold truth of
power and to make sure
that marginalized
voices are heard
and represented fairly
and accurately.
Dread Nation is a continuation
of this work, using action,
wry humor, and yes, zombies,
to explore racism and the power
of structures built from it.
Now I'll get out of
the way so you can see
who you actually want
to see, Justina Ireland.
[ Applause ]
>> Justina Ireland: I brought
this really big bottle of water,
and they gave me a little
one, so it's very awkward.
So you guys have to
pretend like it's not there.
Like she said, my name is
Justina Ireland, and I'm going
to tell you a little
story today.
I'm going to read it.
It's a chapter from
my book Dread Nation,
mostly because I am
woefully unprepared
at every point in my life.
I got an e-mail from my
publicist a couple of weeks ago.
They're like, oh, how's your
presentation coming along
for [inaudible]?
I was like, what?
So kids, be better at
your life than I am.
Let's see.
The section I'm going to read
for you today has zombies
and it's a little violent, so if
anybody's sensitive to violence,
it's not terrible,
but it, it's there.
And Dread Nation is
really about a book,
it's a book about a
girl named Jane McKeene.
And in her world, the
Battle of Gettysburg ends
in a zombie apocalypse,
which seems legit.
And so what happens
is slavery kind
of ends, but really doesn't.
Instead, we have a system
in which people of color
and indigenous peoples are
expected to kind of learn how
to kill the dead, or in
her world, shamblers,
so that everybody
who's in power,
white people, can be safe.
And so this is kind
of her relating the first time
she's ever seen a zombie back
when she was on her, her family
home of Rose Hill Plantation.
Chapter 3, in which I relate my
first encounter with a shambler.
When I was little, back at
Rose Hill, I used to sneak
out of the kitchen, away
from Auntie Aggie, while she
and the other aunties
worked to feed all
of the hungry mouths
on the plantation.
Once they were distracted,
I'd tiptoe out past the ovens
and slip away to
freedom in the fields.
Rose Hill mostly grew tobacco,
which Momma and a couple
of the bigger field hands
would ride into town to trade
for cloth and other essentials.
Early on, back before
I can remember,
Momma had tried growing
tomatoes and other vegetables.
When it became obvious
that her small bundle
of tobacco was worth more
than all the food
combined, she switched.
Momma is savvy like that.
The dead may have risen and
we might have been living
in the end times of Revelation,
but folks still wanted
their tobacco.
The tobacco plants grew tall,
and the leaves were
broad and green.
In the summer, I could
duck down and run
through the rows undetected,
which is what I did
on this particular day.
My goal was always the same.
Find the other kids, the ones
that got to run the fields
because their mommas weren't
ladies who owned the plantation.
The kids I liked best would
be near the barrier fence
at the far side of the tobacco
fields, so I made a beeline
for that patch of trouble.
A barrier fence is the line
of security between shamblers
and the rest of us, and Rose
Hill had three such fences;
white painted fence rails
that had been our original
property line and weren't more
than pretty decoration, a
dense forest of wooden poles
with sharpened ends implanted
in the ground at an angle
that worked like stakes
to impale any shambler
enterprising enough to get
to it, and, at the outer edge, a
wall of five-strand bobbed wire
that was our primary
defense against the dead.
Once or twice a day, the
stronger men would go
out to the barbed wire and end
any shamblers tangled up in it.
Momma would have them
bring the corpses in
and burn them for
the compost pile.
If there were any valuables on
the bodies, Momma and a couple
of the men would
sell them in town,
bringing back something fine.
One time there was a shambler
that must have been a fine lady,
since she was decked
out in gold and jewels.
Momma used the baubles
to buy several hogs,
and that was how Rose Hill came
to have pork chops every Sunday
after the Scripture was read.
But I didn't much care
for that business.
I was more interested
in the children who hung
out playing games in
between the fences.
I scrambled over the
white split rail fence
and carefully picked my way
past the sharpened stakes
of the interior fence.
And there, between the safety
of Rose Hill and the danger
of the outside world,
were the plantation kids.
Everyone on the plantation
but Momma was a Negro,
all except for Mr. Isaac.
There had been other white
men once upon a time,
but after the dead rose
they'd either ran off
or turned shambler.
Mr. Isaac was different.
He came to Rose Hill
after the war.
He lived on the plantation
because he was married
to Auntie Evelyn and
relations between Negroes
and whites were frowned upon.
Momma didn't much care
for, as she called it,
"the spiteful leanings of
biddies with too much time
on their hands," and welcomed
folks into the house staff
as long as they didn't
make too much trouble
and were happy to work hard.
So Mr. Isaac and Auntie Evelyn
lived on Rose Hill with a passel
of boys, the worst of
which were the twins.
Auntie Aggie said
twins were an ill omen,
and anyone who knew the
Isaac twins would agree.
The boys were light-skinned,
lighter than me,
sandy-hued with unnervingly
blue eyes.
They always had a scam running,
like the time they'd stolen
a watermelon from the garden
and climbed up a
tree to share it,
or the time they'd let loose
all the dogs as a distraction
so they could run off
to fish in the creek
on the north side of Rose Hill.
The Isaac twins were
always up to no good.
They were my favorite people
in the whole damn world.
"Hey there, Jane," called
Ezekiel, Zeke for short.
"Aww, Jane's here, now we're
gonna get the strap for sure,"
said his brother Joseph, who
was saltier than Lot's wife.
"I snuck off," I said,
as the other kids began
to give me dirty looks.
"Ain't no one know I'm gone.
What're you doing?"
Each of the kids held a
stick, the end sharpened,
and had the look of
someone with a secret.
"None of your business.
Go back to the kitchens,"
Joe said, picking up a rock
from the dusty ground
and throwing it at me.
The rock missed by a mile,
but the one I picked up
and flipped back at Joe didn't.
It hit him right in the
middle of his forehead,
and as he cried out, I
picked up another rock.
"Next person throws a rock at
me is getting what for right
between their eyes," I
said, shaking with anger.
"No one's going to
throw any rocks, Jane.
You should come with us.
We're going to kill the dead."
Zeke smiled wide and
handed me a sharpened stick.
While Joseph was prickly and
hostile, Zeke was all smiles
and warmth, the kind of person
people liked to be around.
And he had the best ideas.
It was no wonder
Joe was so tetchy.
Who would want to share such a
wonderful brother with everyone?
I took the stick.
"What do you mean,
kill the dead?"
"There's a shambler
stuck in the barbed wire.
We're going to kill it."
"That ain't a good idea."
As soon as the words
were out of my mouth,
I knew it was the
wrong thing to say.
But I couldn't help it.
I liked trouble as
much as the next kid,
but this seemed different.
Dangerous.
"We're gonna kill it so that we
can go on patrols with the rest
of the grown-ups,"
Zeke said with a grin.
"No more chores for us!"
"You can stay here, Jane.
No one wants you tagging
along, anyway," Joe said.
I set my jaw.
Whatever Joe said, I was going
to do the opposite,
just to spite him.
"I'm coming.
You probably ain't found
a shambler, anyhow."
"Oh, it's a shambler
all right," Zeke said.
"You'll see."
We marched in silence, along
the line of the fence rails.
A few of the kids began
to whisper excitedly,
but a single glance back from
Joe shut them up real quick.
My stomach surged and gurgled,
roiling with hot dread.
I'd heard Momma and the
other farm hands talk
about how the dead worked, how
they came out of the brush,
overwhelming the
unwary and wary alike.
That was what made
shamblers so scary.
Even when they were predictable,
they could still surprise you.
As we rounded the corner,
a loud moan split the air.
There, twisted up in the
barbed wire, was a shambler.
We stopped, and all
the celebration
and shouting died
down real quick.
I'd always imagined the dead
as some kind of monster,
mouth gaping as they
came to eat you.
But the shambler caught
in the barbed wire
looked almost normal.
A white woman with long brown
hair pinned up on her head,
wearing a day dress
of green linen.
The skirt was torn, and her
petticoats showed through.
Her eyes were the yellow of
crookneck squash, and the nails
of her grasping hands
had been broken down,
her fingers covered with dirt.
Still, I recognized her.
"That's Miss Farmer.
Her family owns Apple
Hill Plantation," I said.
Miss Farmer hadn't cared for me.
She thought Negroes shouldn't
be allowed in the house,
since we were dirty, but she
loved Momma's blackberry jam
enough that she came
to call every so often,
when it was safe to travel.
"She ain't nobody no more," Joe
said, poking her with a stick.
The shambler growled
and reached for him.
Joe danced out of the way, much
to the delight of everyone.
Even me.
I ain't sure why we
thought poking the shambler
with our sharpened
sticks was a good idea,
but everyone started doing
it, creeping in close enough
to stab the creature
and then dancing
out of the way before
her hands could reach us.
The game might have
gone on longer
if the dead Miss Farmer hadn't
managed to pull herself free.
Barbed wire ain't
a long-term fix
for a shambler wanting
in on the plantation.
Since they don't have any
kind of survival instinct,
it's no big deal for them to
eventually pull themselves free
of such an entanglement,
ripping off great big swatches
of themselves to do so.
And this is exactly what
the undead Miss Farmer did.
One moment, she was jammed
up in the barbed wire,
the next she was stumbling
toward us, half her dress
and a good bit of arm skin
left behind on the fence,
which now listed to one side.
Most of the kids, myself
included, screamed and ran.
I took off for the field
of sharpened sticks,
knowing that would slow
the undead woman down.
But when I looked
over my shoulder,
I realized that not
everyone was with us.
Joe was standing right
where he'd been, not moving,
frozen in the path of the
dead woman and her gaping maw.
The boy had always been
a bully, and the thing
about bullies is they
never learn how to run
like the rest of us do.
So Joe stood his ground,
sharpened stick at the ready,
convinced he was going
to kill the shambler.
At some point in the
woman's lunge toward Joe,
he realized that a stick
wasn't much of a weapon
against the dead,
but it was too late.
Joe was about to be shambler
chow if it hadn't been for Zeke.
It was Zeke that
slammed into Joe,
pushing him out of
the way of the woman.
It was Zeke the woman bit,
sinking her teeth
deep into his throat.
It was Zeke that cried
out like a wounded animal,
trying for a few
precious moments
to push the much
heavier woman off him
as she tore away a
great chunk of flesh.
And it was Zeke that let
out one soft, anguished cry
as his life bled out into
the dirt of Rose Hill,
the sound almost
indistinguishable over the noise
of the dead Miss Farmer feeding.
"Joe," I yelled, and the boy
looked at me, expression distant
and caught somewhere
between grief and horror.
I ran back to where he'd
landed, pulled him to his feet,
and dragged him by the
hand through the field
of sharpened sticks, to
the safety of Rose Hill.
As we ran back, we
passed the patrol coming
to put down the dead.
I didn't stay to watch.
I had seen enough
carnage for one day.
They say when they got there
Miss Farmer had started
on Zeke's face, and that two
of the men vomited before they
even got to putting her down
and driving a nail into Zeke's
head so he wouldn't come back.
Momma gave Zeke a proper
burning, and gave Mr. Isaac
and Auntie Evelyn his ashes.
Joe ran off a few years
later, presumably to one
of the combat schools, and so
their heartbreak was complete.
Auntie Aggie clucked
her tongue and said,
"told you them twins
was an ill omen."
It took me a long time
before I left the safety
of the main house, and I never
ventured into the borders
of Rose Hill again,
not until I came
to Miss Preston's years later.
I learned two valuable
lessons that day.
One, the dead will take
everything you love.
You have to end them
before they can end you.
And that's exactly
what I aim to do.
And two, the person poking the
dead ain't always the one paying
for it.
In fact, most times, it's the
ones minding their own business
who suffer.
That's a problem I still
don't have an answer for.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Now, I have quite a bit of time,
so we're going to
go to questions.
Does anybody have questions?
And it doesn't have to be
a question about this book.
Oh, come to the microphone
if you guys have questions.
I think I can barely see you.
Those microphones, yes?
Yeah? So yeah, go ahead.
>> The best writing advice
you can give to someone.
>> Justina Ireland: My best
advice, the best writing advice
for anyone is to
read, and read widely.
So the thing about, the thing
about reading is we tend
to read the same things.
If you like zombie books, you
read a lot of zombie books.
If you don't like
zombie books, you don't.
And if you like, you know,
like a lot of historical
fiction, you read that.
But the thing about writing is
depending on what you're writing
and depending on who you
read, the craft is different.
So it's really a great idea
to read as broadly as you can.
Read non-fiction.
Read mysteries.
Read romance.
And even if you don't like
romance or [inaudible]
but there's a lot of like
you can learn about emotion
and writing emotional
scenes from a romance.
So if you read widely, what's
going to happen is you're going
to start to understand
how a story works.
Because depending on what
kind of story you write,
there are different tropes
and different functions
within those stories that
you're going to recognize.
And also, you're just
going to learn how
like to really use words
in a way that's different.
Most authors, there's a point
in a book where I will stop
and be like, "that
is so awesome!
I wish I had thought
of that sentence."
And like that is
really going to help you
when you go to the
page yourself.
Next question.
>> Hello.
>> Justina Ireland: Hi!
>> I was just wondering, where
do you get your inspiration
from when you're writing?
>> Justina Ireland: I'm
really angry, so angry,
and the world just keeps
giving me more inspiration.
Yeah, for a lot of
things, so, for example,
like there were zombies
in Dread Nation,
but the book isn't
really about zombies.
It's about a lot of other
things that we deal with.
It's about things like
extrajudicial justice, and,
you know, power structures,
and who gets
to have the American dream
and who doesn't and why,
and what the stories were
told versus the reality.
Because the thing is is like
you can't sit a person down
and like, "I'm going
to talk to you
about racism for four hours."
No one wants that, right?
That is sad making.
But if you're like,
"I'm going to tell you
about historical zombies,"
you're like, okay,
I'm listening.
That's a little different.
And then I can kind of slip
in the important message.
And I think that's
really what you have
to find your inspiration from.
Like what makes you angry?
What makes you happy?
What do you think is
important for people
to think about and talk about?
Because that's going
to keep you on page.
It is really-- you guys,
it takes a really long
time to write a book.
So you have to really be
willing to stick with that story
for that entire time length.
So what-- my inspiration
is what makes me move,
and what makes me move is rage.
Other people, it's love.
Other people, it's
just telling a story.
So yeah. Thank you.
>> So you write, you wrote
a historical fiction book,
and I wanted to ask
you about your research
and other historical
fiction books that you like.
So first of all, what's
your favorite historical
fiction book?
>> Justina Ireland: Okay,
so everyone is always like,
what's your favorite book?
I don't have a favorite book.
And this is why.
I think whenever
you read a new book,
you find a new favorite
book, right?
There's always like--
unless I really hate a book,
in which case I-- okay, I don't
finish a book if I hate it
because I'm not in school
anymore so I don't have to.
And even now, there's like,
you know, the internet exists.
Like when I was in high
school back in the Dark Ages,
like you had to go to the Barnes
& Noble and buy the CliffsNotes
if you wanted CliffsNotes.
Now you can just Google it.
It's like, what?
That's amazing.
But I didn't usually read
a book for 50 pages, right?
And then if I don't like it
after 50 pages, I'm
like, I'm out.
I pull pop smoke and roll out.
Just because it's like I
have-- I don't have time.
And life is short.
And at some point, I will die.
And I don't want my last
spot to be like, oh,
if only I had finished
War and Peace.
So like I don't like read
long books unless they
like really pull me in.
The best historical fiction
book I just read is--
Stacey Lee writes a lot of
these historical fiction books.
And I think her last one she
wrote was Outrun the Moon,
which is about a girl in
Chinatown in San Francisco.
And I tend to write-- when
I read historical fiction,
I tend to read it for
perspectives that you don't get
in the classroom or you
don't get like every time
like 4th of July comes around.
I'm like, I don't
need another story
about George Washington, right?
Like, I know what the dude did.
We get it, George.
But I think like I really want
to know like those perspectives
that we haven't heard
traditionally through history.
I was in college the
first time I realized
that like history wasn't
all just like white dudes.
I was like, oh, crap, there
are other people there too.
Thanks, Howard Zinn.
So like, I mean, like I think
it's really important to like,
to read those perspectives.
And so that's what I
tend to read, okay?
So that was only
your first question.
What was your second question?
>> I was just going to ask
about like how you take the past
and then you twist it like
into a different narrative.
Like how do you do that?
>> Justina Ireland: So
that is the secret to life.
Look, historians do
it all the time, man.
Like all your history
books are like the story
that some dude decided
was the truth, right?
So like, okay, so like my
undergrad is in history,
and like I almost finished a--
I almost finished a master's
in history, and then I
went and did an MFA instead
because that's what
I do with my life.
I never finish things.
But the thing about history
is it's all about people,
and it's all about
people reacting
to the events of the time.
And if you know people, and the
people's mindset at that time,
you can change history to say
whatever you want it to be.
Like I didn't know
until this year
that the Civil War
was not about slavery.
Like that's, that's
amazing, guys!
Like all this time, I
thought it was about slavery.
It's about economics apparently,
or states' rights,
one of those two.
So like the idea is when you're
writing historical fiction,
especially if you're writing,
if you're writing historical
fiction and you're doing
like something I do where you're
taking like a fantastical aspect
and introducing it into the
world, all you really need
to know is these are the
important events that happened,
and these are why
they happened, right?
Because people react
in a certain way
because of their
mindset at the time.
And then you can write a book
where you change all that.
If you're writing historical
fiction, my recommendation is
to read first-person
narratives of the time.
So like I read Twelve Years
a Slave, then I read--
there's a whole bunch
of like first-person--
Frederick Douglass,
right, talks about that.
I have a friend up here.
Sorry. He's like flying around.
And then like you can, like
you can start to read these.
But then also it's important
to read the documents that are
from that time period.
Newspapers are a
great way to figure
out how people think
about the day, right?
Like if you go and you pull
up like the Washington Post
and like the New York Times,
like the Wall Street Journal,
you get a pretty accurate
picture of how messed
up this country is, right?
Because you're like, whoa,
these guys are all
saying the same thing,
and oh, that's brilliant.
And you can do that with
a lot of local papers.
When I went to-- when I did my
undergrad in Savannah, Georgia,
and it was a bachelor's degree,
and it was like for
your final project,
you had to like basically pick
like a week of Savannah history
and tell the story of that week.
Because that's really
what historians do.
They take facts and
they interpret them
and they tell you a story.
Sometimes those stories
make sense,
sometimes those stories
are just them trying
to get their Ph.D.
certification.
But that's what you do.
And so I was reading this story
in the Savannah Morning News,
which was the paper at the
time, and it was literally
about how people were
mad at this mailman.
Like the postal carrier had
like embezzled funds, I think,
because I guess at some point
in history, the post office
like held people's money.
And people like really
wanted to kill this mailman.
And so there were like
letters to the editor,
there were different
reporters talking about this.
I mean, it was a
postal carrier, dude.
Like they were mad.
They were really
mad at this mailman.
And I was like, this
is brilliant.
Like this tells you, like this
tells you how important the mail
is today.
I mean, nowadays,
we're just like,
why do we each have
the postal system?
Let's cancel it, right?
So like, I mean like, so I think
that's really what you're--
when you're writing
anything historical fiction,
the biggest important
part is the people
and the people's story.
And that's one of the reasons
you have to kind of read widely,
because a lot of
times the people
who are telling the history are
not the entirety of the people
who existed at that time.
So you want to find those
hidden stories as well.
>> Thank you.
>> Justina Ireland: Thanks.
Is there another question?
Please be another question.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Hi!
>> Justina Ireland: Hi!
Thank you.
>> You're very interesting.
[ Laughter ]
>> Justina Ireland:
Did my mom call you?
>> I will be honest.
The reason why I say that is
because I'm a high
school librarian,
and I have a book service
through Junior Library Guild
that comes every month.
And your book, Dread
Nation, came through.
Had never heard of it,
never heard of you.
And interestingly, it just
came a week or two ago,
so I haven't had a chance
to look at it and read it.
And it's on my desk.
And I'll see it on Tuesday
when I go back to work.
But what's interesting
is for years, off and on,
I've tried to get teens to
understand the importance
of history and reading.
And when you first started
talking and reading your story
about zombies, I'm like,
what does that have to do
with racism, this,
that and the other?
But listening to you,
I'm going to go back,
I'm going to read the
book, and then I'm going
to see how I can come up with
ways to pull in your story
as a means to cook them.
It's a different way of
presenting information
that they need in a way I
wouldn't have thought of,
and that's why I said
you were interesting.
>> Justina Ireland: Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
>> Justina Ireland: I'm going
to take that as a compliment.
>> It is.
>> Justina Ireland: The
thing about zombie stories,
they're never about
the zombies, right?
The zombies are like this
really gross metaphor
for everything you hate
in the world, right?
And so George Romero's zombies
are literally about capitalism
and what capitalism
does to people
and how it makes people
just kind of awful.
There's a book called The
Reapers are the Angels
by Alden Bell.
It's a zombie book.
And it's literally a book about
grief and how do you let go
of those things that
don't exist anymore.
And so like when you read
a zombie book, if it's just
about the zombies, the
author did something wrong.
Because like really running away
from a rotting corpse is
only really interesting
for about 50 pages, and then I
close the book and put it away.
And so like, like really
zombies, there is a book,
it's an academic book, so,
I mean, it's a little dry,
but it's called Better Off Dead,
and it's literally a series
of essays about what zombies
represent in the culture.
The first introduction
of zombie-lore
into this country was after the
United States occupied Haiti
in the early 20th century, and
it was kind of these stories
to try to talk about
how like Haiti was one
of the few countries
in like the, you know,
western hemisphere that
was completely independent
of like water rule, right?
So we all know-- do we all
know the story of Haiti?
Okay, yeah?
Yeah. Someone said, "yeah."
Everyone else was like, "ah!"
Okay, so Haiti had a revolution.
Woo! Yay! We've having a
revolution in the early 1800s.
Basically, all the people who
were enslaved said, "hell, no,
we're done," and
killed everybody.
They killed all the landowners.
A lot of people fled
to New Orleans,
which is why you have kind of
like that like French and Creole
and like those very like, you
know, mixy-mixy kind of cities,
and these different
cultures kind of clashing.
And then like after
they destroyed
and burned all the plantations
and took all the
land of [inaudible].
France came in and said, "hmm,
you cost us a lot of money.
You need to pay us money.
You need to pay us,
because that was wrong."
And the United States was one
of the countries that was like,
yeah, you need to pay
them, like, right?
And so these very like,
these very terrible kind
of like reparations
were put into Haiti,
and so Haiti became-- that's
why Haiti is still a very poor
country to this day.
But the first like incidence
of these zombie-lore was
because Vodun was
the, like the coming
of the practicing religions
there, and it's tied to a lot
of West African beliefs.
And when American soldiers
went and occupied Haiti
in the early 1900s, they
were like, they're dancing
in the fields, and they're
dead, and oh my gosh,
these crazy black people!
And literally the evolution of
the zombie myth is oh my gosh,
crazy black people, which
is kind of funny today
because it still keeps going on.
And so like that's one
of the things about like
when you're talking about
history and you're talking
about myth and you're talking
about what does a
zombie really mean,
because stories are never
what they say, right?
A dragon isn't really about
like a fire-breathing lizard,
you guys.
Like a dragon sits
on a gold hoard.
It's about people
who control wealth,
much to the detriment
of others, right?
Like so these fantastical or
fantasy metaphors like exist
in all the books we read.
It's just like are
we seeing that?
And that's really I think--
I mean, like my friend,
Dhonielle Clayton, wrote
a book called The Belles,
and in this society, nobody
has, nobody has any features.
Everyone was kind of born gray.
And these magical women who are
beautiful make them beautiful.
But the book isn't
really about that, right?
The book is about
slavery, and the book is
about beauty standards, and
it's about all these other
like very complicated,
hard-to-talk-about subjects,
because again, no one
wants to hear you talk
about beauty standards
for four hours, right,
but they will read a book.
And so that's really
like when you're back
to like getting your kids to
like connect with history,
like there are kids who
love historical fiction.
I was a kid who loved
historical fiction.
I didn't love like not seeing
myself in historical fiction.
That sucked.
But you know what's even
better than historical fiction?
Zombies, because you can't
get away from zombies.
And I don't mean that like as
like ooh, zombies chase you.
I mean that more
like in the culture.
So yeah, so I think like
that's where when we read,
especially in YA, YA, why
you only read things about YA
as a category is it has
the flexibility to say,
I'm going to teach you important
things about race, with zombies
and some more history, which
you don't necessarily get a lot
of in other categories,
each categories.
Adults are too bitter.
Like we're too like,
we're like, whoa,
what are these zombies doing?
That would never happen, 50
pages later, so, you know,
kids have a little
more flexibility.
You've been so patient.
Thank you so much.
>> Oh, no problem.
What are you reading right now?
>> Justina Ireland: So okay, so
right now, my brain is so tired.
I'm reading a romance book.
What is it called?
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, yeah, the one
with the sword maker?
>> Yeah.
>> Justina Ireland: Yeah,
that's what I'm reading.
I haven't started it yet.
I just bought it,
and I have like,
I have a really early
flight tomorrow.
I'm like, tomorrow?
You with me, guys?
I love romance.
I think the world is a
burning trash fire right now,
so romance has been
like my go-to.
And so like yeah, so I'm really
excited to read this book.
The last book I read that I
really loved was The Mere Wife
by Maria Dahvana Headley,
which is not a romance.
It's the retelling of Beowulf,
but Grendel's mother is a
PTSD war vet, and it talks
about the nature of
monsters, and like who gets
to be a monster and who gets
to be-- live in a castle.
And it's just like--
I'm getting chills.
Actually, I want to put an
air conditioner in the book.
But anyway, it's a
really good book,
and it's not a very long book.
It's like 200 and I
think 70 pages, which,
to me, is a short novel.
And so it's really
worth it, yeah.
So those are my lysical
[phonetic].
I love lysical [phonetic] books.
They're like, they're
just so nice.
And then Maria Dahvana
Headley's Mere Wife.
>> I loved-- oh, sorry.
I loved Dread Nation
so much, and you've put
in such a cliffhanger, I
can't wait for the sequel.
>> Justina Ireland: Me too!
>> Yeah.
>> Justina Ireland:
Writing is so hard.
>> Yeah, but, you know,
one of the things I really
loved was how relationships
like evolve and change, or
the sense of mystery with Jane
and her mother, and then
with Jane and Katherine.
So I was wondering, because it's
not a spoiler, if you could talk
about Jane and Katherine,
and maybe sort
of your thought processes
behind that,
the inspiration behind
that, female friendship.
>> Justina Ireland: Yeah, okay,
so if you haven't read the book,
it's like a minor
spoiler, but not really,
because you knew it
was going to happen.
But in the beginning of the
book, Jane has a girl she hates.
She absolutely hates this girl.
This girl is like her
competition to be best
at the school, and she's
like, whatever, she sucks.
Also, she's light-skinned,
so she's [inaudible]
because she could pass as white.
And by the end of the
book, they're friends.
Because I really am so
tired of girl hate tropes.
Like really when I sat down to
write it, it was like, oh, yeah,
she hates it because she's
blonde and she's pretty
and she's good at everything.
And then by the time I got
halfway through the book,
I was like, man, this sucks,
like this is terrible, Justina,
you need to fix this, because I
rarely have those conversations
with myself while I'm writing.
And so I want to talk
about female friendships.
So in YA, we have so
many romances, right?
And I love romance.
But that is not the most
important relationship
in your life.
Like, I mean, like
okay, and I say this
to somebody who's been
married like 20 years,
but like the female friendships,
like especially for women,
the friendships you have,
the friendships you develop,
and why those friendships
work or don't work,
why they fall apart, to me was
like something I really wanted
to talk about and explore.
And I also wanted to talk
about that difficult mother
relationship, which I actually,
fun fact, talk about
in all my books,
because all my characters
are angry
and have these fraught
relationships with their mother.
And not because I have a fraught
relationship with my mother,
but because that mother/daughter
relationship is really the first
female relationship
you have in your life.
And I say female,
but like obviously
that includes anybody who, you
know, considers herself a woman.
I don't want to try to limit
that to just like biology.
But like that is a very fraught
relationship in your life.
And at some point,
it comes from--
it goes from being nurturing
to competitive, right?
In everybody's life, it happens.
It doesn't necessarily happen
between fathers and daughters
because the competition is
not necessarily the same.
And I want to talk about, I
want to talk about the idea
of competition between
women, because I think a lot
of times we let ourselves fall
into these really terrible traps
about we're in competition
with each other,
but it's like no, we're not.
Like don't take this the
wrong way, but men suck.
And they're like, like making
you think you're in competition
with each other so they can
sell you body cream or sell you,
you know, pimple cream,
or like make sure you're
so busy fighting with each
other, you don't notice
that they're taking everything.
And so I wanted to talk
about that, like this idea
of like a female friendship.
And then also kind of like
poke fun at the YA trope
of like the mean girl and the
girl who like, who torments her.
Yeah, I just think, I just think
relationships with women are
so like-- it took me
a really long time.
So before I was a
writer, a long time ago
when I was a little
baby, just, you know,
I was in the Army, right?
And every-- thank you.
And every girl I knew
in the Army was not
like other girls, right?
But we were all there
together doing the same thing,
suffering the same
things, right?
So I really wanted to take
that trope and kind of stab it
in the eye because we're
all just like other girls,
which is why we should all try
to figure out some common ground
and support each other.
So that was my feminist
platform.
Sorry. I'll put my soapbox away.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Justina Ireland:
You're welcome.
All right, I have two minutes,
so if anybody has any
one last question.
We have time for
Go ahead.
>> What's the best way to
convey emotion in your writing?
>> Justina Ireland:
You would have
to ask somebody who's actually
good at writing emotion.
[ Laughter ]
You're like, I read your book!
You're lying!
Thank you!
For me, I don't write
emotion in the first draft.
And the first draft
was mostly just events
and people responding
to those events.
Emotion comes later, when I
know where the story is going,
and where I know where
the character arc is.
I would say the best
way to buy emotion is
to visualize the scene.
What is the character
doing with their hands?
Where are they moving?
You know, like when I'm nervous,
you can see I talk
with my hands, right?
So I'm all up here with my
hands, like [inaudible].
When I'm sad, I'm probably
looking down at the ground.
So just think about like what
people do with their bodies
when they're feeling
a certain way.
I mean, you can tell me
you're sad, but if you say
like her eyes were downcast
and her shoulders slumped,
that conveys the emotion better
than saying, "I'm sad," right?
So think about that physicality.
So all right, you guys,
that's all I have.
Thank you so much
for staying it out.
[ Applause ]